hello everyone welcome to this special
edition of Hannity I'm Tammy Bruce in
for Sean and tonight with Thanksgiving
just a few hours away the White House is
reminding Americans to be thankful for
Joe Biden's tremendous record of
accomplishment that's right today they
published a list of everything we the
people should be thanking them for from
gas prices now roughly double under
Biden to the record levels of unfunded
spending that caused inflation to Rising
taxes and planning on raising them even
more on everyone except of course for
those making above four hundred thousand
dollars a year and here's everyone
here's one more thing to be thankful for
according to the Biden Administration
they are now encouraging institutional
investors to prioritize climate change
over profits finally a new rule from the
labor department allows investors
overseeing your 401ks or Pension funds
to forego that pesky profit in order to
consider quote the economic effects of
climate change in other words they can
now throw your retirement savings into
Fringe green technologies or other woke
causes and lose your money with zero
consequences not that that's ever
happened before meanwhile abroad more
bad news in Ukraine the war continues to
rage and will likely continue
indefinitely in Iran the
administration's precious nuclear deal
has fallen apart as Iran's supreme
leader is now openly referring to Biden
as demented and let's God help us and
let's not forget about the vice
president's big trip to Asia watch this
please
thank you hello
hello
thank you
did she like urge the first one to go by
fast it's hello thank you
we are not in good hands I think we know
this hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else